the Joe Rogan experience yeah did you
ever think about doing something like do
you get revelations post training do
some other things that I always have
after like really good hard workouts
first of all I'm always feel filled with
gratitude yeah I'm always like really
thankful yeah after long hard workouts
and I've thought about doing this thing
called the gratitude series where I do a
podcast like immediately after like
really hard workout nice and just talk
about my feelings and that mean it
sounds [ __ ] corny and and
self-indulgent but but realistically I
think there are some lessons that I
learned off of really hard workouts you
know where it's like at the end of it
you know when it's all done first of all
there's always this feeling like eight
out of ten times I don't want to work
out mm-hm
really eight out of ten I work out ten
out of ten
uh-huh but eight out of ten I might [ __ ]
this you're always happy always always
and that's the hump man yeah that that
[ __ ] hump of just shut that part of
your brain up and just start moving and
then once you start moving you start
breaking a sweat once you start breaking
a sweat it becomes easier it starts
feeling good then you start getting some
satisfaction like oh I almost didn't do
this today Here I am doing it and you
know and then sometimes it's [ __ ] you
know sometimes I'm looking at a
three-mile run which is nothing for you
but a mile in I'm like [ __ ] two more to
go Jesus Christ and I'm running hills
eat [ __ ] but when it's over it's like
yes you know when I get back to the car
and I'm saying hi to people hey what's
up wave it in the neighbors dogs
exhausted I'm happy everybody's pumped
you know it's like and I feel good I
feel warm I feel friendly I feel loving
I feel you know I want to call people
and tell them I care about them it's
like it's like there's moments like
post-workout in particular where you
just feel really good and I think life
is sometimes about getting over those
periods of feeling kind of shitty or
low-energy or lethargic or unrest it or
whether the [ __ ] it is and just pushing
through that because you know the
territory you
there before and then developing a habit
of being able to do that and being able
to know and have faith in the process
and understand that this yeah yeah yeah
I know you don't want to do it shut the
[ __ ] up and go just go yeah once you do
go you always feel better yeah no I
hundred percent agree and I think in my
own training like I get that from a lot
of different workouts but the one that I
really love is like when I get closer to
a race and I saying before you start
dialing things in to be more specific to
the to the activity you're trying to
prepare for I'll do a phase of training
where I'm running kind of in an area of
about like 150 155 beats per minute so I
can go like on a oh it's it's just fast
enough where I feel like I'm really kind
of like working but it's also Sloane if
I can go for quite a while so I can like
log a really big run and when I was
training for this last race that at the
Pettit Center I had a training cycle
where I hit I had a four week block
where I had one D load week which is
just basically a reduction of volume and
intensity and three billers they're
called D low d load because I'm like
reducing volume and intensity and the
other three though were build-up one so
I had like 130 mile week some right
around hundred thirty and then 250 mile
weeks and they were just like basically
loaded with like kind of just faster
than or right about kind of hundred mile
intensity so you know I would do and you
can maybe pull it up I think I have a
picture on my Instagram page of the I
did these key workouts where I'd go to a
track and I would just do loops around
the track and it'd be like anywhere
between 27 to like 32 miles at that kind
of intensity and you just get into like
a flow and a rhythm and it just once you
kind of get moving it feels great and
afterwards yeah you you feel great the
whole rest of the day and you just want
to kind of go out and do it again you
almost have to be careful not to not to
do too much but who structures those do
you structure them yourself yeah yeah I
took can I go back to what we were
talking about in the beginning like when
I structure a plan ideally I start out I
start out with a good base a good
aerobic base which I typically kind of
retain almost year-round I'll take like
offseason but I like to follow principle
where I'll let myself kind of lose some
of that peak fitness just so it's
sustainable because staying at your peak
fitness level is not sustainable
so I let myself get like just out of
shape enough so that I'm not always at
that level
and then I start kind of building in the
the structure towards the race itself
which starts with those shorter faster
intervals since they're further away and
then I get closer and closer to the race
where I'm doing things that are more
specific so like the next step would be
I'd be doing some longer intervals or
kind of like what you consider like an
anaerobic threshold type workout which
generally speaking is about like your
max intensity if you did like a
60-minute all-out time trial and then
you know that's still not specific to
100 miles because I'm out there for 11
hours so I'm kind of still moving closer
to that slower race pace
yeah and it's a it may just follows the
principle of you know hitting all the
systems of training like you would in
any other period eyes endurance plan but
always keeping that compass of the stuff
you do for the earth intensity of the
race itself is the type of work you
should be doing closest to it so you're
really just optimizing when you're
closer to the race itself how do you
know what your peak fitness is like when
you say that you wanna you can't really
maintain the peak fitness you want to
back off a little bit so that you can
just keep your your training running how
do you know where that is and how do you
know that you cannot expand that and
then ya know that's a great question
that's somewhat subjective too I mean
you can analyze things if you want to go
into like heart rate variability type
things if you but that's a little more
on the micro level for me personally
like usually I'll get to a point where
like I'll do a race and you know you can
just kind of tell like I'm exhausted
from that and I like to think of it kind
of two folded where like physical
recovery and mental recovery so if I do
a big race and afterwards like I can't
even like bring myself to think of
another big training block I know I need
to like let myself kind of get a little
bit out of that fitness state that peak
fitness state and just kind of reset
their hidden reset button so this is
just from years and years Tyler and you
make mistakes I mean in the past you
know a lot of times I'll do one other
guy think I got one more race left me
then it goes badly so right now what is
a long day like say if you're getting
prepared for this 100-mile race and you
know you're gonna have to run for 11
plus hours what's a long day for you
yes so the longest
I did for this particular one was three
and a half hours it was I think 32 miles
or something somewhere in that
neighborhood I'll do I'll do
I usually don't push up much past five
hours in my own training if I'm gonna do
much more than that I'll just jump in a
race like the nice thing about Phoenix
is there's a race company called air
Viper and they put on like 30 some ultra
events every year so it's not Wow you
can basically it's almost every weekend
pretty much yeah that's crazy
so like the the guy who raced direct at
Jamil he he'll he'll let me jump in
events when I want to and so sometimes
all if I'm gonna do something like say I
wanna I'm preparing for 100 mile and I
want to get a really long day like a
seven eight hour session in you know
I'll just pick like a like a hundred K
type event or like you know a 50 mile or
type event and just do that at like I
like to say like I try to eat those are
you know those a training tool so I
don't want to necessarily race it all
out but if you can kind of keep yourself
at like maybe eighty percent of what
you're capable of you can get that good
long stimulus but not necessarily beat
yourself up so much that it takes away
from the race you're preparing for and
so fifty miles would take you or how
long would that take you it depends on
the course like I just did a 50-miler
actually about a week and a half ago
called the JFK 50-mile that took me five
hours and 42 minutes and that course is
kind of it's got you go over the
Appalachian Mountains for about 60 miles
and you get on a really flat toe path
for about a marathon and then some
rolling Street Hills so that's not as
fast as you can find you can find I mean
you can go on a track how much elevation
you're going down that one was about
3,000 feet so haha it is but the funny
thing about ultra marathon especially in
North America is like you know the
trails are where a lot of you know
there's a lot of interest there so 3,000
450 is actually considered a relatively
flat fast course whoa
you know it's hilarious it's really
interesting too because like some of the
I live just about two hours south of
Flagstaff and there's a group of ultra
marathon guys who train up there and
they I got a lot of inspiration from
from two of them specifically for this
last race that race I did the Pettitte
Center and one guy's name is Jim
walmsley and he's for my money probably
the best ultra marathoner we have
certainly in North America if not the
world I mean he he's got the course
record at the western states 100
which is the most tested hundred-mile er
in North America
he's got the course record at the Lake
Sonoma 50-mile by a pretty big margin
he's actually at the two fastest times
but the next closest person him is like
18 minutes behind or something like that
and then he's also got the course record
at the JFK 50-mile the one I just was
mentioning before and these three events
are three of the most tested courses
that we've had and he's got the course
records at all of them and he can
probably go faster so I mean some of his
training is like he'll do like 150 mile
week sometimes with like 30,000 feet of
climbing and ascending and the kicker is
one of his training partners Jared Hazen
so if Jim is the best ultra runner in
North America has from the male side
Jared Hazen is by far the most
underrated so this guy he ran the
western states 100 this year Jim
finished first
Jared finished second Jim broke his
course record by running 14 hours and 9
minutes on a course that has 17,000 feet
of climbing in 23,000 feet of descent if
you ran a hundred miles with that much
yeah in 14 hours in westerns yeah in
western states is considered a running
course for the most part - like there's
crazier ones that get way worse from a
climbing descending Bob yeah we have to
use trekking stick yeah yeah yeah
so Jared though Jared so Jim he had
actually broken the course record the
year before and he took like I think was
like 16 or 17 minutes off the old course
record around 14 and a half hours this
last next year he broke his course
record with the 1409 Jared came in
second and I think it was 14 23 or 26
just behind Jim basically pushing him
all day so any other time Jared would
have won that race except for that year
and it would have been like you know a
huge story for him and you know it just
I mean it was a amazing performance when
those two guys and just watching kind of
their training and then their
performances cuz I was out there crewing
and pacing my wife it was a huge
motivator for me when I kind of got into
the training build-up for that race at
the penet Center so wow it's it's it's
it's just funny with ultramarathon
because you have such a variety again I
think we talked about this a bit the
last time as on you can have like these
kay races that are like I mean there's
50 cases at 10,000 feet of climbing and
descending and then you can have these
six day events that are on a 400 meter
track right which is much different yeah
[Applause]